welcome to this video playing chess
heroes not just one chess hero outside
it's a bunch ok we have them an English
opening ok maybe it's going to do the
terrazzo but should be salmon yeah maybe
the turusch if he goes to the hive now
ok we get to this by taking with a night
yeah that's uh that's a possible line
it's not very attractive I believe but
it's it's ok it's it's playable currency
to not sure it's um it's a bit uncommon
this t1 maybe start with this pinning
pinning the Queen
hmm
okay what I shouldn't do is 95 and so on
f2 but multiple ways yeah I can also go
Bishop g5 asking him what the queen is
going to do yeah shouldn't shouldn't be
a bad bad end game early let's see how
to continue you 493 as one possibility
yeah maybe i'm not and not spending a GM
it's probably going to be somewhat
better for wine in any case maybe i
should have gone to see 21 he is right
into into a possible forks okay so II
five maybe a five gaining even even more
space
to maybe be five coming okay yeah maybe
just look here on night c5 is he going
at night be five is he going for might
be five maybe hmm
possible maybe cavity 5 yes but it's not
like I thought this this was the idea
it's difficult now for him to keep me
five um okay I can take now take be 50
this is D for hanging I seem before I
mean is hanging yeah it's still probably
better to take first push it takes
ok can cover cover this first
could wait if i take night before group
d 1 is a double attack you cannot cannot
take on before night yeah it's a double
attack is it not oh okay it wasn't
really difficult to see I still
overlooked it um not good and 93 SS also
in the position yeah I really managed to
spoil this fantastic position not easy
but at the moment I am very very capable
of doing those things knight c6 or might
be five
yeah it's not really leading to much in
any case
time warning yes spent no time on this
game absolutely no time three minute
twenty unbelievable
I hope I'm getting somewhere finally
please them getting a pawn
so I've got the a pawn and possibly the
H porn so let's let's run the a pawn
to be six is a good spot
controlling controller controlling the
black rook and now I'm entering with the
king this fruit this should be good even
worth 35 seconds check check
well just need to get get the King back
here
check yeah it's not not really tricky
with 20 seconds check
yeah it's fun it's promoting
black resigns yeah still I managed to
screw up this great position yeah
overlooking very very simple things here
at the moment like 95 I was really
thinking that rookie wanna sighs it's
very good this means that I need to do
something else here yeah 94 is good yeah
that's better just leaving them this
night on b5 where it is if this idea
okay well with the the weakness it's
also a good position but it's not not
that clear that it seems that here this
is better check but i was thinking
however one upon the computer skin it's
going giving you this one I don't
understand it's just due to a back rank
made like here this is this is very very
strong Wow yeah this is very strong the
idea is up is the mate look here if he
takes check check then you can check
play something like that I actually
thought it wasn't made as well but yet
maybe it's after this inmate yeah this
one made him check check check mate it's
very nice so very good very good line
here by the comp there should be three
but difficult to see in a blitz game
yeah at least at the moment I don't
think I'm going to find this stuff will
take take yeah this is nice with the the
back rank ideas check and I was really
thinking I want to pawn which I didn't
meant iam it's like nothing less than
nothing
maybe it's it's it's still about equal
dish but he played everything instantly
him and f6 is just blundering yeah you
should take take on e five years still
ok for black and after that i'm
basically winning i think i got the
better look better bishop and to be five
as a weakness yeah that's that's a big
edge for black / white very very big
edge so he gave away the porn even
immediately okay thanks for watching